little red spring and I threaded it
through a binder clip the binder clip is
carrying a passenger underneath let's
say that which is the top of the
mountain and we are designing a
funicular I wanted to carry this
passenger up to the top of the mountain
summit of the mountain how can you do
this one solution is to just lie down
the stream with a crease and then make
the whole thing go up load but I don't
think the engineers will accept this
solution so what we do is to keep those
two strings absolutely parallel
no cheating but then plugging them in
alternating fashion so start start start
that and look the clip starts going up
spontaneously towards summit of the
mountain that strange that because if
you are just looking at the visioning in
one hand
what I'm doing is up and down up and
down and it's a purely symmetric motion
up and down up and down so there's no
directionality and if anything gravity
is pointing downward
I mean this should keep coming down but
instead by doing a completely symmetric
up and down motion I can take this thing
upward in a way that breaks the symmetry
and it prefer to go up and not come down
so that is rather strange and the
wonderful thing about this is the zip
work even if you're not paying attention
you know it's a really simple device and
even if you are not paying attention and
being distracted by so it's not my
friend ready there I can just do this
and then we're going to be coming down
instead so that's that's wrong so I'm
just watching the same thing
no no it's coming down it's not going up
to what is going but you know if I am
paying attention and okay so this is
this device and if I'm repeating paying
attention I'm not being distracted
camera or anything then I can do this
focus Terral and tuck tuck tuck
it does go oh yeah what we are doing
suppose the keeping the strength pedal I
tug on the left one well I let go the
right one and when I do this initially
you see to exaggerate a little
this clicked turns a little cyclist but
that means you see that this string is
touching the left part of the clip only
lightly where the right one is entangled
will be with a clip so this produces
more friction and in fact a static
friction where this can slide and that
the dynamic friction and we discussed
the dynamic friction is slightly smaller
than static friction when I do this this
sliding friction wants to pull the clip
down and this friction wants to push the
clip up but because the right friction
is the static and entangled friction and
the left one is a sliding and free
friction and this push up is stronger
than this pull down that's like in this
slope it goes up and similarly when I
pull the right one and deaf-blind
now it twists like this left one gets
pulled up by the stronger friction where
is the right one which is now pretty
free can slide along these strings and
doesn't pull down so that's why I've
been going back and forth over controls
like this
even if we keep it horizontal I mean
this up and down business is a red
herring
it's purely a function of how the thing
is threaded through this binder clip
that determines which way cause if I do
it for example down in still goes
because the binder clip clip is slave is
that right well when I turn it around
then the binder clip comes my way or
download it into same thing oops
truthfully make the slick end of the
experiment I have to tie a habit oh yeah
no we got it okay I have to have some
more tape behaved exactly the same way
we're at 45 degrees off you get